- Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our daily Homeroom live stream.
For those of you who are
wondering what this is,
this is something we
started a few months ago.
It was really just a
way to stay connected,
have interesting conversations
about education and other topics.
And I'm super excited
about today's conversation.
I just had the macadamia nut,
so I'm gonna drink some water, sorry.
(laughs) Sorry about that.
There wasn't a lot of water in there.
That's why I had to kind of lift it up.
But before I jumped into our conversation
with Jonathan Haidt,
I'll get my standard announcement.
A reminder that kind of Khan
Academy is a not-for-profit.
We can only exist because
of philanthropic donations.
Your position to do so.
Please think about it.
And special thanks to several corporations
who stepped up in the
last couple of months
to allow us to accelerate
our response to COVID.
We were running at a
deficit even before COVID
in that deficit has only grown,
especially thanks to Bank
of America, Google.Org,
AT&T, Fastly, and Novartis.
And we're still running at a deficit.
So any help either as an individual,
or a corporation, or a
foundation is much appreciated.
So with that,
I'm excited to introduce Jonathan.
Jonathan, we've seen each
other at several conferences.
We even have some funders in common.
Thanks for joining us.
- My pleasure, Sal.
And let me also just say thank you
for all you're doing for us
parents during quarantine.
My wife and I were pressuring
my son to pick something,
pick something to learn.
So he went to Khan Academy,
and he's taking your JavaScript course.
Thank you.
- Well, we are honored to be of service.
And for everyone listening,
we're gonna be taking questions
for Jonathan and myself
if you're interested.
So please put the comments
on YouTube or Facebook,
wherever you're watching.
And we have team members
who will surface it.
But Jonathan, you have a
fascinating job area of research.
You are a social psychologist
focused on the psychology of morality.
What is that?
And that'll help people start
thinking of questions, too.
- Sure, okay.
Well, so morality refers to the fact that
we're always judging each other.
We don't just live in a physical world.
We live in a world made
of norms and expectations.
And those keep us in line,
they give us endless things
to talk about, gossip about
they lead to conflict, endless conflict,
but morality also makes
possible cooperation.
We're an amazingly cooperative species.
Bees are more cooperative than us,
but not a lot of other creatures.
So cooperation and conflict,
that's a lot of what I study.
And that has brought me
into the study of politics,
in particular.
I used to look at how morality
varied across cultures
and beginning as the
cultural war began to heat up
in the United States in
the 1990s and early 2000s,
I began to look at how left and right
are like different countries.
- Yeah, I definitely
want to talk about that.
I'm sure there's gonna
be questions about it.
When you look at your three
publications, kind of common,
every day I read a publications
outside of academics,
you have three books.
One is The Happiness Hypothesis:
Finding Modern Truth in Ancient Wisdom.
I'd love your big takeaways there.
And I am curious how
it's affected your life.
Your other one is
The Righteous Mind:
Why Good People Are Divided
by Politics and Religion.
And then most recently
The Coddling of the American Mind:
How Good Intentions and Bad Ideas
Are Setting Up a Generation for Failure.
And so that'll also help prompt people
to think about what questions to ask.
But I mean, let's just go in order
from The Happiness Hypothesis,
this is something I spent a
lot of time thinking about,
about how to optimize not only my own life
but how to optimize generally society
so that we can be happier.
What are kind of your takeaways?
I mean, how has it
affected your personal life
when you did this research
to look at each with them?
- Sure.
So what the book is,
it grows out of my course at
the University of Virginia.
I taught there for 17 years,
and I would try to present
psychological insights to students.
And I would often use quotes
from the ancient East and West.
And I found that there's
a small number of ideas
that have been discovered
in almost every society.
Like, "There's nothing good or bad,
"but thinking makes it
so," as Shakespeare said.
And that's the basis of cognitive therapy.
So I wrote a book one
truth in each chapter,
and I reviewed what's the
modern research on it.
And the book wasn't supposed
to be about happiness,
but it turns out that if you
take a lot of ancient wisdom,
there are a lot of connecting threads
on how to live a good
life, how to flourish,
and I'll save you all the
trouble of buying the book.
I'll summarize thousands of
years in a couple of sentences.
(Sal laughs)
What it comes down to,
is happiness doesn't come
from getting what you want.
Okay, that's very short, lived.
Happiness comes from within
more, so that's better.
But really the best way to
summarize the human condition
is that happiness comes from between.
That is...
Pardon me.
It comes from getting the
right kinds of relationships
between yourself and others,
yourself and your work,
some sort of productive work
and yourself and something
larger than yourself,
having a sense that your life matters.
You're part of something bigger.
And if you get those
three conditions right,
you're gonna be about
as happy as you can be.
So we all have a kind of a set point,
a general level of
happiness that we return to.
But if you get those
three conditions right,
you'll sort of be generally above that
at the high end of that range.
So there you go.
The secrets of happiness.
Trust me, it's a lot more
interesting when you go it slowly.
I shouldn't just cut to the
chase and given you the answer.
- No, well, I think I have the book,
and then I encourage
everyone to go through it.
But there's a lot that I talk a lot about
on this about my own journeys
and meditation, but I do.
And we also talk about how
important it is to have a purpose
and feel like you're
contributing to something larger.
And so that definitely
reinforces my existing beliefs.
And as you also write
about confirmation bias,
it's a very (laughs) (indistinct)-
- And just to make that
connection that's right.
It always feels good to be proven right.
And it's often hard to prove people wrong.
- (laughs) That's right.
And then related to that,
I think that gets into
a lot of what you've
been focused on lately,
including with your not-for-profit,
which is, it's clear that
there's significant polarization
politics is by definition,
always somewhat polarizing.
But there is a scent,
and you probably have evidence
that it is unusually polarized right now.
I'd love if you have any
evidence that it is truly,
it's not just an intuitive sense
that it is measurably
unusually polarized right now.
And also, what do you think
are the sociological cognitive reasons?
And then maybe we could go
into how do we depolarize
or if we think we should.
- Sure, Okay.
So as you said, politics
is by nature polarizing.
You have parties that
represent groups of interests
or identities or whatever,
and then they compete, and
elections are zero-sum.
So there's nothing wrong with that.
And even some degree of polarization,
like peoples, are far apart on views.
It's not necessarily bad.
But think of it this way,
suppose you have a sports league
in which the Yankees and
the Red Sox hate each other,
just theoretically.
That can actually make the game more fun,
but suppose they hate each other so much
that they start hiring hitmen
to kill members of the other team.
And they do things to sabotage the field.
Okay, now you're like,
you're totally out of bounds.
This is not what the game is.
Now let's turn to American politics.
So there's some debate
among political scientists
about what polarization means.
And if you think about like
views on on policy issues like abortion,
by some niches, we're not
more polarized than we were.
As a psychologist, I focus on
one thing and one thing alone.
That is an effective polarization,
which means emotional,
how much do you feel emotion, negative?
How much do you hate the other side?
That's what's crucial.
And the data shows very clearly
that in the '70s and '80s,
and even into the '90s,
Republicans, and Democrats,
they rated the people on their side
and the parties on the other side,
sort of little a little
negative, but not at the bottom.
And the ratings began to
get extremely negative
in the late '90s is when it begins.
And then it goes down and down and down.
There is such hatred now
that this has a lot of ramifications.
One of which is
we are now really willing
to believe almost anything.
If you hate the other side,
you're much more willing to
believe crazy stuff about them.
So that's one whole piece
is rising polarization.
And then let's add in
the change in social
media and in cable TV.
So we now have a media ecosystem
that is really well designed
to find the most anger-provoking,
outrageous stuff it can be totalized,
but it's gonna funnel it in.
And so for a lot of reasons
where now we're in a democracy,
which has to have a public square
in which ideas are hashed out.
And we generally make progress.
We improve ideas when
sometimes there's compromise,
I mean, that's what we need
to do to live in a democracy.
And I think it's much
harder to do that now
than it was even 10 years ago
to say nothing of 20 or 30 years ago.
- And what do you think it was in the '90s
and then it sounds like it
accelerated in the last 20 years
that caused this?
I guess you could say
amplification of polarization
or judgment of other side.
- This could be mess, yeah.
So, our minds like to look
for a thing that happened,
'cause you see the curves,
and they really do begin
to dip in the '90s,
and you might say,
"Oh, well, it must've been,
Newt Gingrich or Fox News."
As you thought you're safe
if you're on the left,
you'd certainly point to that.
If you're on the right,
I imagine you'd point to Bill Clinton.
But what I like to do is
these are complex systems
that have a lot of parameters to them.
And I like to think of what are the forces
that are kind of pulling
any complex system together?
What are the forces that
are blowing it apart?
And a lot of them began
changing around this time.
So for one thing,
we have to see the late 20th century
as an historical anomaly
when our democracy had lots of problems.
But we thought democracy
was the ultimately
the way that everyone was gonna live,
once the Soviet Union
imploded, we thought,
"Wow, liberal democracy
with free-market capitalism,
"this is the end of history
everyone's gonna go this way."
What we didn't realize is that
democracy is actually really, really hard,
and the founding fathers
and the Federalist Papers,
they really worried about
our tendency to faction,
to split apart and hate the other side.
So I'll just point to a couple of factors.
One is the loss of a common enemy.
So from Pearl Harbor and world
war II, through the Cold War,
having a common enemy really
binds a group together.
That's a big one.
Another really big one
is the media environment.
After World War II,
we had three television networks
that had a fairness doctrine.
So they had...
They couldn't be very political.
So for awhile, we had a media system
in which we kind of all
got the same sort of news.
And then once you get cable TV,
and then the internet,
and then social media,
now you go from broadcasting to everyone
so that we all hear the
same stuff to narrowcasting.
And of course,
people using Facebook
data and advertising data
that really micro-target.
So we're not on the same page.
We don't believe the same things.
We're in a state of moral
and factual incoherence.
And we may be that way
for the rest of our lives.
So those are a couple of big ones,
but there are many others
that began changing,
and the result is hatred,
distrust, distrust of each other,
and distrust of institutions
has been rising steadily
to the point where I
think extremely dangerous.
It's really not clear what's
gonna happen to our country.
- I know you're out in the
business of predicting,
but what do you think is...
What do you think is a
natural extrapolation
from where we are right now?
If you go out five or 10 years.
- Oh boy.
Well, put it this way.
If current trends continue,
then our country would probably fall apart
in a catastrophic way.
But please don't quote me,
I know people are watching live.
Please don't me-
- Well, that is the statement
that I was expecting you to say.
- Wait, I got to finish.
I gotta finish it,
because if current trends continue,
then I think we will be in big trouble.
But the thing is, current
trends never continue.
This certainly not continue forever.
And if you zoom out,
if you take the big picture
and you look at both human history
in which life is getting better,
rights are being extended.
Science advances, knowledge...
The big picture life is
getting better and better.
And then there are dips,
but then it keeps rising.
Steve Pinker has books like
The Better Angels of Our Nature.
There are a variety of books
that have really tried to
encourage us to realize
in every age, people
think things are terrible,
and they're going to hell,
but actually, things are
generally getting better.
So it's always been wrong
to bet against America.
And I think in China and
a few other countries,
they are enjoying our mess
for geostrategic reasons.
Odds are, we'll figure a way out of this.
So my short answer is
I can't predict I think
there're variety of scenarios
in which things look
even scarier and weirder
next year and next year or two.
But we're likely to find ways out of this.
We have to solve a lot of problems.
We've got to improve so many
things about our democracy.
The way we vote,
the sense that people have
a voice, gerrymandering.
There's all these problems
with our democracy.
And I do hope that if things
change politically next year,
that democracy reform and improvement
will be very high on the agenda.
- Yeah, and you talk about the importance,
I guess, of a common enemy
to hold people a little
bit closer together.
And obviously, we are facing
something of a common
enemy in the pandemic.
And from YouTube, Sutton, asks,
do you think...
Well, this is more of
epidemiological question.
Do you think it will have a second wave,
and it sounds like it already is, frankly,
but if we do, how do you
think it'll affect society?
Will it cause Democrats and Republicans
to have a greater divide,
or will they finally come together?
- Yeah, so let's back up and go back
to those healthy on early
days of the pandemic
when we were all trying to come to grips.
It was inconceivable that we'd
have to shut everything down
and stay home for months, inconceivable.
And as we came to grips with it,
and as that happened,
it like, "Oh my God,
everyone is doing this.
"This is a global thing."
And in those first weeks,
that was the big question
people were asking,
"Is this gonna bring us together?"
But let's step back here
and understand what happens to societies
when you have a foreign attack
that brings people together
when you have a pandemic in history,
that divides people apart.
You may have a disease coming in.
People are afraid of each other.
There are shortages.
So pandemics traditionally have
actually split people apart.
Now this pandemic is different
because we didn't have food shortages.
It wasn't that deadly like the plague.
I mean, it wasn't like, half
the people were gonna die.
And it was an amazing shared experience.
So in the early days,
the polling showed many
more people were saying,
"We're all in this together."
But here's the amazing and messed up
and tragic thing about our country.
Our culture war is so severe
that within, it took about four
or five weeks by mid-April,
the pandemic itself had
divided the country.
Now, I think a lot of
that can be laid directly
at the foot of the
president who was tweeting,
"Liberate Virginia," things like that.
So both the president,
the media environment,
within a few weeks,
we had to left over to wearing masks,
over the speed of opening up,
over so many other things.
So I don't think that the pandemic
will help or bring us
together at a national level.
Now, locally, lots of great stuff happens.
So you got to look at multiple levels,
but overall America has
handled this pandemic
horrifically, incompetently,
and of course,
you can blame many actors and agencies,
but a portion of the
story is our polarization.
We don't trust each other or authorities.
- Yeah, and it related
to this, or maybe not,
I mean, you tell me.
Your most recent book,
The Coddling of the American Mind,
has this played into this polarization?
Has polarization played into that?
Or is that just another
orthogonal dimension
to what's going on in society?
- Yeah, so briefly,
The Coddling of the American Mind
is about the big changes
that we began to see on
campus and in high schools,
as Gen Z came in.
Gen Z, people born in 1996 or 1997,
depending on how you count it.
But around that mid-90s.
Their childhoods are different
from the millennials,
and their mental health
profiles are different.
They have much higher rates
of anxiety and depression,
nothing else, really just
anxiety and depression
and is especially-
- How much high?
Is that well documented, the rate?
- Oh yes, it's very well documented, yes.
If you go to the coddling.com
somewhere on the front page,
I have a link to a giant Google Doc
where I've collected all
those studies showing
on any side, is it rising?
And then a second document
is social media part of the cause.
And when we started this with this...
Was originally, the insight
was from Greg Lukianoff
when we started this
with Lukianoff on, 2015,
everyone on campuses
were across the country
talking about the rise
of mental health needs.
But we didn't have any hard data on it.
And by 2016, 2017,
now all the survey data
was showing this is real.
And it's not just self-report.
It's not just that Gen Z is
comfortable talking about it
because you find the same
increase for self-harm
and you find a similar
increase on suicide.
So this is behavior,
it's not just changes
in diagnostic criteria.
So we're trying to understand why that is.
And I decided a portion of it,
especially the sex difference
may be, or seems to be doing part
to the effect of social media,
especially on middle school kids.
Social media really
changes around 2011, 2012,
in that for 2009 to 2012.
But the other piece is
the vast overprotection
that Americans put on kids.
And it happened in Canada and Britain too.
We stopped letting them
out to play as much.
We got really scared about abduction,
and we overprotected kids.
Kids most need to grow
socially as free play
and supervised free play,
where they get in conflicts,
they work things out themselves.
So that's what that book is about.
No, I don't think
it doesn't tell us much
about the pandemic,
but yes, we should
definitely talk about it
as an educational nonprofit.
I don't know, actually
Sal, are you seeing any signs of this?
I mean, your audience is
mostly, I would guess, Gen Z.
Are you seeing signs
that Gen Z is different
from millennials or old
previous generations?
- Well, the very nature of Khan Academy,
we are removed physically.
So we're only engaging in
kind of through the exercises
with the videos that they might watch.
And so we don't see it as directly
there's other kind of
non-Khan Academy outlets
where at least, I hate to admit it,
but as a middle-aged person.
I'm like, "Oh, these youngsters
now they are so different."
- Welcome to the club, yes.
- And I wonder whether
this is just something that
every generation goes through,
once all of a sudden you turn 40.
And all of a sudden,
you think you're not that
different than a 25-year-old,
but you realize that cultural difference.
Or maybe they're just
like I was when I was 25.
(laughs) I'm different now when I'm 40.
- Yeah, no.
It's true that each generation
thinks the one behind it is lazy or...
Every generation criticizes
the one behind it.
And often the criticisms are the same
across thousands of years.
So you're right to wonder that.
But if you look at the mental health data,
something really happened around 2012
is when the lines began
going way, way up for girls
and up, not as much up,
but still also for boys.
So these are objective
measures of mental health
in terms of those that are behavioral.
So it is.
And the other thing I can say is,
I've spoken about the book
at many high schools and
universities to Gen Z audiences.
And I laid out the case.
Here's what we think is happening.
And I was asked them, do
you think this is right?
Or, I said something,
painting your generation a certain way.
And overwhelmingly, they
say, it's a correct portrait
because they recognize the
effects of overprotection
and of being on social media so heavily,
Gen Z is not in denial.
What I've seen is they generally
want a broader range of experience.
They wanna be exposed to ideas.
They wanna grow up to be
stronger and successful.
- And so, you have these two factors,
the social to social
media fails to understand
that these would have been kids
who are essentially entering
adolescents around 2012, 2013,
which is right when, obviously,
I mean, social media had already
started to gain momentum,
but around 2012, 2013,
it became huge, your
Facebook, your Instagram,
Snapchat of the world.
And what do you think is this,
how does social media connect?
And there's a question
if I can still find it
where someone was asking,
I think it's off of YouTube,
do you think that is it a net
negative that social media
or are there kind of
from bouncing influences?
- Sure, so yeah.
The important thing that
people need to understand
about social media
is that it really changed in two years.
So it comes out, you get,
Myspace and friends joining
Facebook around 2004,
and it's, "Here I am, here's my picture.
"Here are the bands I like.
"Here are my links to my various friends."
That's not toxic.
That's not bad for anyone's mental health.
In 2009, Facebook adds the Like button
and Twitter add the Retweet button.
And now there's a huge amount
of information on engagement.
And everybody is
reinforcing everybody else.
It's almost like an operant
conditioning experiment,
with James...
Anyway, the behaviorist
conditioning experiments.
And so you have so much engagement data.
Now, the platforms use that to
algorithm size but they feed.
And so now social media
becomes much more addictive.
It lures many more people in,
and it creates an outreach machine
that is now it's very
easy to drop something in
and it spreads.
And so by 2012, the meeting
environment is different.
Now, the newspapers, the old line media
has to play the game.
Advertising shifts onto Facebook,
by 2014 this thing is so powerful
that the Russians who've been
messing with our democracy
since the mid 20th century,
the Russians activate all their networks
to make us even more angry at each other
and put in a lot of lies
and a lot of manipulation,
a lot of fake sites.
So 2014 now, it's like,
we've got this where our public squares,
this outreach machine
being directly manipulated
by other countries
and by bad actors within this country.
And so I think that's when 2014, 2015
is when our politics really
felt like it was going haywire.
And this, I believe,
is made possible and
opening for Donald Trump.
I don't think could have been elected
in a normal election year.
But he was very skilled
at using this free media.
So I just wanna make the point,
people have to understand,
it's not just like being on social media,
it's being immeshed in this
stream of constant judgment
and outrage, and it's exhausting,
and it's especially bad for, I believe,
for middle school kids.
So, I'm not taking a position
on whether adults should use it.
But I think 11, 12, 13-year-olds
really should not be on it.
They certainly should not be on it
without the permission of their parents,
but at present, anyone can
sign up for an account.
There's no verification.
And you see kids get sucked into this,
and the chronic anxiety about
being judged about conflicts,
high cortisol levels
extended over, days, weeks,
months is bad for development.
- And this is really interesting.
'Cause just as an observer,
I think a lot of people will say,
"Oh yeah, social media,
it makes you insecure,
"maybe anxious because you
see other people's best lies.
"They're going on vacations.
"They have perfect.
"They look perfect in the
morning, et cetera, et cetera."
And you feel insecure
about your very real life
you're saying, and
maybe that's part of it,
but you're saying,
it's something a little
bit different is that
it's reinforcing views in a bubble
and allowing to feel kind of
moral outrage about another.
And the other is not even in your bubble.
So they're not even in a
position to defend themselves.
And so that causes the anxiety.
'Cause you're just looking at it.
You're like, "I can't believe
there's half the country
"or half the world that is that crazy,
"that they're after me
"they're after people I care about."
- Yeah, well, not exactly
let me separate two different things.
There's the mental health effects
which seem to be especially
prominent in early adolescents
and especially in girls.
So when social life went
from lots of face to face,
gathering together with your
friends, to doing it online,
where there's constant judgment,
and anything can explode
that I think is particularly
bad for teen mental health.
That's one piece of it.
Then there's the democracy piece,
which is not about kids.
And it's not about anxiety.
It's about anger and the
ability to find truth.
And so that is a part of the reason
I think that our democracy
is going, haywire.
And why we're seeing
some similar movements in
many Western countries,
there's all kinds of economic causes too.
I don't wanna oversimplify.
But I was born in 1963.
I'm a product of the 20th century.
My generation, we were raised to believe
democracy is the greatest
thing, it conquered.
It was better than all other systems.
And if you're born in 1996,
and all you've seen is the 21st century,
it's not so clear that
democracy is this great thing.
I'm not saying, it's not,
I'm just saying it's not
working that well these days,
and it's not just an
American then it's happening.
And I think social media is a part of it.
It's not most of it, but
it is an accelerated,
it just makes...
It's exactly what the
founding fathers feared
that faction and conflict
will spread like wildfire.
- And so what...
And these are two fascinating threads
that are probably related
to the mental health thread,
what's healthy for young kids.
And then what that may be
doing broadly to a generation,
maybe if that's playing a
role in our polarization.
There's several questions here.
I just saw it.
There's so many questions
I'm having trouble scrolling,
but there's a question about,
what recommendation would you have
for parents of adolescents?
You take them off of social media,
do you keep people to
cage so they don't care-
- Yeah, so the media company-
- 'Cause they don't care?
- Yeah, so, the easy
thing would be to say,
"Don't let your kid have social media
"until they're 16 or 18."
That would be an easy thing
to say, but it wouldn't work.
So the first thing is to differentiate
between screen time and social media.
So it's not screens per se that are bad.
So spending time on Khan Academy,
of course, you should get
some exercise during the day,
but spending hours learning coding
is not bad for you in any way.
So it's not screens,
it's specifically social media
where you're making content,
and then you're looking,
"Who said, what about it?
"What are people thinking of?"
So it's specifically social media,
and the effects seem biggest
on younger adolescents.
So my advice...
Okay, and then the third
thing to add in here is,
we're all trapped in a game
we're all trapped in a situation in which,
when I told my son when
he started sixth grade,
that he couldn't have Instagram,
he said, "But almost everyone
else in my class has it."
So it was harder for my son.
Very few people wanted their
kids on, but we're all trapped.
And every parent says,
"Well, okay, if everyone else
is on it, I'll let you on it."
So I think we have to have leadership
from middle school principals.
We have to have leadership.
Parents have to get together.
We have to have a common agreement
to keep kids off of social media,
at least until high school.
I think that's the clearest thing is
it should not be in middle schools.
Kids should have a...
It's hard enough to be in middle school
with all the gossip and all the changes
and all the growth and
all the embarrassment.
Get it out of middle school.
And I think we would then see
these rates of exciting depression.
I think they would come down somewhat.
- Yeah.
- One more thing.
- And when we're competition, go ahead.
- Sorry, I would just
say also now for parents,
I think it's also important
to talk with your kids
about what kind of childhood they want.
Because as far as I've found,
Gen Z is actually pretty reasonable,
and they don't wanna spend
their whole lives online.
And so helping them set limits
because you've got all these psychologists
in Silicon Valley working
so that if you give your kid
a device, they'll stay on it.
So this makes no sense
to give your child's time over
to this psychologist in Silicon Valley,
you and your child should decide
and then use the Apple screen
time controls or whatever.
I think those work very well.
And also agree on
a time that devices
come out of the bedroom.
That I think is very, very important.
Otherwise, kids get sucked in at night.
They're doing it.
It can interfere with sleep.
It just can go on forever.
- Do you really hire psychologists
at social media companies-
- Oh my God, yes.
- To learn how to drive the
addiction factor up or the...
- Absolutely, oh, my goodness, yes.
I mean the psychology of slot machines,
the psychology of engagement,
oh yes, they hire a lot of psychologists.
There's a lab at Stanford
that trained a lot of designers
in how do you hook people?
How do you keep them on your product?
Yes.
- Yeah.
And then we do a little bit of work.
Obviously, we think we're
doing it for a good purpose
for how do you hook someone
on to learning or engagement,
but we don't have a team
of cognitive scientists,
but maybe you'll do it (laughs).
- Try to get.
Well, if your goal is to
help them finish a lesson
and reach a goal that
they themselves endorse,
then that's just good psychology,
and I'm sure you have all kinds
of points and rewards built,
and that's good psychology.
It's when you're trying to
undercut their own resolutions
and trying to keep them on
even longer than they'd like to be on.
So if you look at the regret factor,
how much are you...
How happy are you with the time
that you spend on Khan Academy?
I would guess-
- Is that Sal?
- Excuse me, hello.
- Say hello to the live audience.
- Hello.
- Okay.
- Hello. (laughs)
- I would guess that if you ask kids,
how happy are you with time?
Do you wish you spend...
Do you feel like you spent
too much time on Khan Academy?
Well, okay, if the
parents were forcing them,
maybe they'll say it's too much,
but if it's self-driven,
they'd be happy with it.
- Yeah, no, I mean these conversations,
we could talk for several hours,
and hopefully, we can have you back on
'cause each of these threads,
I think we can double and
triple and quadruple click on,
maybe just to kind of finish
up maybe on a positive note,
I know you're above and beyond
your academic research and your writing
you're involved in trying to change
maybe at least not only observed,
but maybe deep polarized society.
We have this question from
Facebook, Cathy Gifford Grans,
what positive actions can individuals take
to mitigate some of the negative impact
of increasing polarization?
So, what should we do
collectively or individually?
- Thank you.
Thank you, Cathy, for that question.
So a lot of the big changes
are gonna be systemic changes
in elections and media
and all sorts of things.
But all of us as individuals,
all of us are caught up in a system
that makes us hyper moralize.
And so to go back to the
happiness hypothesis,
one of the great truths
is that we're too judgmental.
Is that...
Here let me see, I actually
have some quotes here.
Let's see.
So this is something
you hear from all over,
"Judge not lest ye be judged."
Buddhists says, "Hatred
never ends through hatred
"by love alone; does it end."
Sengstan says, "When love
and hate are both absent,
"everything becomes clear and undisguised.
"Make the smallest distinction, however,
"and heaven and earth are
set infinitely apart."
We are so judgmental,
and we also have the capacity
to understand people.
And when we do that,
we lose some of our anger,
and we can talk to them.
So what I would recomend
is everybody realize
we're caught up in endless
streams of outrage,
and you as an individual
can step out of it.
Can reach out to people,
can try to understand them.
I recommend, especially the book
How to Win Friends and Influence
People, by Dale Carnegie.
It'll give you almost a social superpower.
You have the capacity to
actually persuade people
to actually connect with people.
And social media pulls us
into this conflict mindset,
but you'll be much more
successful in life.
If you try to understand
people, persuade them,
and learn to work with them.
At very least it'll help
you in your own marriage
and with your own children.
- And related to that, I
know we're already over time,
but there's another really good question.
It also will help tie a bow on this.
There's a question from
Facebook, John Hepworth,
is there a way to detoxify social media?
You're having these debates.
I know Facebook is struggling.
Do you take off certain posts?
And even if they're from
the president or not,
and there's really kind
of a no-win situation,
you're gonna make someone upset,
and then there's free speech rights,
but then there's the page,
there's all these things.
What would you do if you
were Mark Zuckerberg,
would you edit speech?
Would you change the platform
in some way to make it less
toxic or to detoxify it?
- Yes, I think it's essential
that we make the platforms less toxic.
There was a report in the Wall
Street Journal a month ago
about how Facebook had.
They had studied polarization.
They had thought about ways to reduce
the degree to which it
exacerbates polarization,
and they dropped it.
So I think Facebook,
there's a lot of responsibility here.
There's a lot more that
they could be doing.
Twitter has hardly any social
psychologist on its staff.
I think Twitter needs to really
start studying these issues.
They've taken a couple
of steps here and there.
I have an article in the Atlantic
with Tobias Rose Stockwell last November,
in which we laid out a few
steps that could be done.
One is to add friction here and there
when you're about to post something
that seems to be particularly
aggressive or toxic.
You can add little bits of friction,
but that's a small thing.
More algorithm accountability.
And the algorithm...
Most people are pretty reasonable.
This is wherever I go.
Most people are pretty reasonable,
but the algorithms give much
more voice to the people
at the extremes that
people are not reasonable
'cause they generate engagement.
We need to understand those algorithms,
and there needs to be
some public comment on it,
some way to change the algorithms.
I think the biggest bang is
gonna come when we find ways
not to have to go after
each individual post
but to reward users who are
civil and show some nuance
and some constructiveness.
And so, if I could mark people
who I think are particularly
or not me marking.
If there were ways to code
for integrative complexity
or civility or constructiveness,
if the platforms could code for things
so that I could set, "You know what,
"I don't want anybody
who scored score zero.
"I don't want trolls
"who just their content
is very predictable.
"I want to cut them out
so that they don't see me
"I don't see them."
We would all have a much, much
better life on social media.
So I think this is one of the trends.
If this keeps going on, I
think our public square,
our ability to talk to each
other is in big trouble.
I think we're gonna have
to have major reforms
to social media that makes it less nasty
less conspiracy generating,
less outrage generating.
- Hey, one question.
And I know I keep asking
questions over time,
but I mean, it sounds
like some of these reforms
would just be bad business for these comp
'cause obviously, it's oftentimes
the more extreme statements
the things that are generating outrage
that get you sucked in,
that make you wanna comment,
that make you click on something.
And it's not the social media,
as you mentioned, our
mainstream media or TV media,
or print media-
- I think of it a lot too.
- They've also discovered
this business model.
- That's right, yes.
As many have commented,
the business model is such
that we are not the customers,
it's the advertisers
who are the customers,
where the tuna fish that
gets hooked on the hook
and delivered to the customers in a sense.
So yes, the business model
will have to change ultimately,
but I would put it this way.
So I teach a course at NYU Stern
on professional responsibility.
It's our ethics course.
And one of the things that becomes clear
when you look at all these cases
is that in the short
run, cheating often pays,
but in the long run,
ethics generally does pay.
And so, in the long run,
if people really hate
Facebook and the more...
We're seeing that this month,
boycotts can be extremely costly.
And if there's all kinds of
people wanna boycott something,
well, if someone comes
up with a better product
that is not as tox...
That does not lead to such toxicity.
Facebook would lose market share.
So, in the long run, I think ethics pays.
And also, most of the people
I met in Silicon Valley
it's full of idealistic people
who really think or want to believe
that they're making the world better.
So I am hopeful that some
big changes will happen,
but big changes have to happen.
- Yeah, well, Jonathan,
you've given us so much to think about.
I encourage everyone to take a look at
all of Jonathan's writing.
You said, the coddling.com.
- You could go to the coddling.com.
Yeah, you can get
everywhere else from there.
- To get some more data.
But, Jonathan, thank you so much.
This was extremely insightful.
And you've given me a lot to think about.
- Great, my pleasure, Sal.
Thanks for all that you and your team do
to educate the world.
- Appreciate it, all right.
So thanks everyone
for joining as always these conversations.
I don't know.
I reached out to him, saying, "Oh yeah,
"I got maybe 10 minutes
worth of questions."
And then we realized 40 minutes go by.
So thanks for joining
as you saw Jonathan
fascinating his research,
I can spend several hours
on every one of those
topics we talked about.
But thanks for joining this week.
And I think we're off to...
Well, actually, I'm not gonna say that.
I think we're off
tomorrow, but we will see.
But I will see you at
the next live stream.
See you then.